hi everyone I'm Rosemarie Miller and we
are backstage at the Forbes 30 under 30
Summit and I have the pleasure of
speaking with the CEO and founder of
retool David Sue David thank you so much
for joining me excited to be here are
there any other titles you'd like to add
to that before we keep going oh no let's
go let's go so David what what's your
background and also tell me the
inspiration for rol yeah so uh rol is
sort of enterprise software company we
started actually because we had a lot of
problems as developers ourselves
Engineers ourselves building sort of
internal software and so we're like
maybe there could be a faster way of
building all the software so that's how
we first got started mhm so how is AI
kind of affecting retool yeah it's
actually sort of a really big Tailwind
for us in the sense that I think a lot
of people now are looking a lot of
Enterprises especially are looking to
how can I sort of Incorporated AI how do
I build more apps that use AI Etc so
it's a real tail innd for us which is
pretty exciting I love how you're just
like and just of like built retool no
David no that's just not how things were
lot of things went wrong along the way
talk about tell me about some of those
things that went wrong I'm sure someone
would appreciate it yeah well let me
think what's a stressful moment um so we
went through this accelerator called
White combinator um and uh White
combinator happens twice a year and uh
at the end of every batch uh there's
something called a demo day which is
sort of where everyone goes and presents
uh sort of your idea and what you worked
on for the past few months
and uh the idea that we initially worked
on actually was so bad we didn't even
want to present it and so it was uh
actually kind of embarrassing to some
extent because all of our friends that
we were in the batch with were going up
and presenting and raising money and you
know we felt so proud of them we so
ashamed ourselves we're like wow we have
nothing going on we have nothing to
present we really want to come back you
know in 3 or four months so that I think
was sort of a pretty uh low moment if
you will where we were really doubting
like hey are we you know starting the
right company are we doing the right
things so so how did you overcome
that uh it was hard to be honest um I
think we were really lucky to have sort
of a bunch of advisers around us so for
example my combinator uh sort of some of
the group Partners were very supportive
and they were like hey look a lot of
startup ideas don't work out the first
time actually uh you know we funded you
guys not because we thought the idea was
great in fact we thought the idea was
bad but we really believed in you uh and
I think hearing you know someone sort of
say such supportive things obviously was
very helpful uh and getting through uh
they really believed in you what was it
about you that they believed in oh you
should ask them if I had to guess it was
it's probably something along the lines
of I think probably uh one of the most
useful skill sets of starting a company
is be able to learn very quickly and so
sort of approaching company building and
sort of a uh I have some ideas about the
world but look I'm probably wrong you
know some percent of the time let we
learn about which areas I'm wrong and
being sort of open-minded and sort of
low ego I think is a uh quality I hope
to have so did you feel lucky to know
that like wow they believed in me they
didn't really believe in my company
because think of all the pitches people
must hear and all the NOS they give out
like did you feel lucky oh yeah
definitely I mean I think just give you
a sense like when we were raising our
seat around uh this was five six years
ago I think sort of it's like every
story you hear basically you end up
getting something like 100 NOS basically
at 3 S's and of course the three s's are
what matter uh and you feel great about
that but you do go through on you Nos
and so the 3 s's at some extent are
lucky but uh it's certainly uh there's
certainly a lot of luck and I'm you know
fortunate to have benefit from something
so when you hear though no those NOS do
you think okay we need to we need to fix
something after each no or do you just
think they weren't for
us it's mostly the ladder but it's
probably somewhere in the middle uh I
think that if you want to start a
successful company you do have to be
open-minded like you're probably going
to be wrong about things and so uh you
know uh behind let's say 100 NOS
probably like 90 of them it's you know
just not a good fit for example be but
behind 10 of them there maybe is sort of
some uh learnings that should take away
I'm like oh maybe I like presented or
pitched this sort of the wrong angle or
wrong way and that triggered something
in that other person and so they said no
for that reason so I should you know try
not to do that in the future so I
certainly think uh NOS are useful for
learning but I don't think you should
sort of over rotate on every no you get
item so it's kind of a fun balance so as
an entrepreneur let's say someone has a
job that they don't really like and
they're thinking I'm going to quit
tomorrow to pursue my passion would you
say go ahead and do that and I don't
know pray that you're going to stay
afloat or you know stay in your current
position in in weight so I think this is
a great sort of 30 under 30 thing too um
which is the best time to start a
company if you can is when you're young
uh when you're in school actually
ideally because at that point it's sort
of uh you have a lot more free time if
you will whereas if you're working let's
say like I don't know 9 to 7 at a
company you it's going to be hard to
find the free time with the energy
really to go start a different company
or start a new idea which takes a lot of
energy and so I've always and I think we
were just really lucky that sort of the
idea for ret orderly came from uh us
having worked on a bunch of side
projects when we were actually at school
and that was really helpful cuz during
school you can work on so many things
right so I think starting young is ideal
if you can uh otherwise I would say I
think it is risky I have a lot of
friends now who's starting companies uh
without any idea these kind of quit
their job they're like let's see what
happens that I think is really dangerous
think you really want to have an idea at
least and maybe ideally have proven out
it out a little bit before you leave
your job but you know I think it's it's
a balance too it was dangerous but did
it work out in the end it did uh for me
it did but I don't uh like you said I
was I was lucky right and so I think if
I were to flip this coin you know 100
times for example is it going to look
like this you know 100 times certainly
not so so what advice do you have for
those who want to become an
entrepreneur h
I think the entrepr skill set actually
is a pretty sort of distinct one it's
sort of one where uh sort of like before
mentioned you have to be open-minded be
low ego be open learning stuff like that
but you also have to have conviction in
your beliefs for example and so maybe
one thing I would maybe uh challenge
people to sort of think I think starting
a startup now has become sort of this
exciting thing that a lot of people want
to go into I'm actually not sure
everyone should be starting startup
actually really so U well you may not
have the personality for it like for
example if you are let's say say uh too
open-minded I think that's probably bad
because you don't sort of have enough
conviction sort of in your own idea for
example if you're too let's say
close-minded also doesn't work either
because you're again going to be wrong
about some large percent of things
actually and so I think having sort of
that lgo willingness to learn openness
to learn openness to feedback stuff like
that is actually a pretty sort of
critical skill set I think for starting
a company and all the czzle founders I
know have that and so you don't have
that like maybe you should think about
that for for a second before starting a
company so absolutely well David before
I let you go I'm I'm curious what is one
thing you do every single day that you
believe contributes to your
success I read quite a bit uh so reading
is a lot of fun uh I think it uh sort of
different books serve different purposes
for me I really like fiction for example
fiction I think is sort of great for
building empathy seeing the perspective
of of others non-fiction different
purpose yeah well thank you so much for
joining me today thank you
absolutely